prendre appui sur une manifestation
sportive pour sensibiliser la population
est l'objectif de ce match son diabète
beh y est venu faire du baby time
pourquoi parce que c'est un sport pour
les diabétiques et toi tu dis oui
diabète
oh ça veut dire quoi que
créé à ce bas il marche il
il peut plus faire de l'insuline eh ben
j'ai besoin d'une pompe pour pour avoir
dû lâcher à gossau soeur de tous bords
ce muscle et jean enfin si il paraît
apte à être en bonne santé
ces petites filles courageuses joue au
badminton comme n'importe quel enfant
une organisation orchestrée par une
association de parents et d'amis
d'enfants diabétiques dont cette maman
fait partie la journée ce match tombe sa
bête
voilà est une manifestation proposée par
l'association caritative solibad et
en marge de la du tournoi international
de saint denis
donc
l'association des bébés johnny bas de
réunion a proposé
voilà de cette journée ce match tombe
diabète ben en fait c'est vrai que chez
un enfant diabétique
voilà le taux de glycémie ça va faire ça
monte et descend en août et d'essence
d'amis car des ipo faire des ip avec
tout est telle que la pratique du sport
voilà pourrait permettre voilà de ne
plus avoir ses courbes là bas le message
en fait c'est de faire comprendre aux
enfants que c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
diabétiques que le sport leur est
interdite ou voilà bah je peux pas faire
ça parce que je suis diabétique non au
contraire ils sont aussi capables que
n'importe quel enfant
et voilà venez n'ayez pas peur fait du
sport que ce soit du bas de football de
voilà ce que ce que vous voulez défoulez
vous amusez vous voilà le diabète de
l'enfant diabète de type 1 qui se
déclarent jeunes et qui est une maladie
auto immune on a absolument besoin d'un
traitement par insuline et il ya le
diabète de type 2 dont on entend
énormément parlé à la réunion thiel
diabétiques de l'adulte qui se développe
de plus en plus c'est le chez les
adolescents mais c'est avant tout une
maladie adultes et on n'a pas forcément
besoin dans un premier temps d'insuline
c'est une autre maladie qui fonctionnent
d'une autre façon et c'est important de
faire la distinction entre les deux pour
le goûter des frais j'ai ça vous ai
passé un bon après-midi manger bouger
autour du jour sportif
les messages passent et la réunion n'a
besoin trois fois plus de gens sont
touchés par cette maladie par rapport à
la moyenne nationale
plus il y a deux personnes sensibilisées
à la maladie du diabète plus ça permet
de faire de la prévention à grande
échelle et d'éviter que enfin essayer de
freiner un petit peu le développement du
diabète de type 2 pour le coup à la
réunion le sport comme réponse comme
lien social ou encore comme traitement
avec plus de 180 mille six cents
licenciés ces disciplines accessible à
tous et peut être une solution globale
badminton déjà c'est un sport très
ludique qui est accessible dès le plus
jeune âge et c'est un sport ou pratiquer
partout on a tous joué sur la plage dans
son jardin et ça nous a pris goût et
donc après on est venu dans les gymnases
et on a vu que le badmington ça jouait
sans vent et et on s'éclate tout de
suite tout de suite tout de suite c'est
le sport numéro un du nez cesse depuis
très longtemps est loin d'être détrôné
donc ça prouve que les gens s'amusent en
venant jouer au badminton
la prévention est nécessaire le calme en
mai la mobilisation de chacun est
obligatoire encore plus quand il s'agit
d'enfants
toi merci d'être venus vous êtes bien
amusé